ganz in der nähe von eisfeld in
thüringen hat der landkreis
hildburghausen diese kreisstraße gebaut
kosten für das schicke stück asphalt
rund 280.000 euro aber die schöne neue
straße dürfte es an dieser stelle
niemals geben der grund sie liegt auf
einer historischen bahntrasse die bis
zum heutigen tag nicht entwidmet wurde
die straße ist ein behördlicher
schwarzbau aus meiner sicht ist es ein
verantwortungsloser umgang mit
steuergeldern wenn eine straße auf einem
gewidmeten barbaren damm gebaut wird
es ist nicht in ordnung was ich da
gemacht habe das ist so viele fehler und
ich machte mich stinksauer ich bin
darüber so entsetzt können sich gar
nicht vorstellen ende 2019 baut der
landkreis hildburghausen die kreisstraße
530 auf die alte trasse der werrabahn
die hatte bis zur deutschen teilung
eisfeld und coburg miteinander verbunden
die schienen sind zwar längst entfernt
worden doch die trasse behält ihren
status als bei an gelände
die bahnstrecke könnte wieder
reaktiviert werden wir uns das eisenbahn
bundesamt bestätigt wurden keine flächen
entwidmet bzw von bahnbetriebs zwecken
freigestellt hier darf laut gesetz keine
straße sein
jeder soll es wissen wenn es uns eismann
geht gibt eine eisenbahn aufsichtsrat
nämlich eisenbahnbundesamt und
eisenbahnbundesamt muss auf jeden fall
in solchen sachen eingeschaltet werden
es wurde definitiv nicht gemacht und
auch das thüringer landesamt für umwelt
stellt unmissverständlich fest weil kein
planfeststellungsverfahren durchgeführt
wurde ist der bau rechtswidrig steht
seit dem jahr schon von einem schwarzbau
und seit dem jahr wird mir gesagt das
ist kein schwarzbau jetzt hat man
schwarz auf weiß dass es ein schwarzbau
ist im landratsamt versucht man die
fehlenden genehmigungsverfahren mit
thüringer landesrecht zu erklären weil
nach thüringer straßengesetz für
kreisstraßen ein
planfeststellungsverfahren nicht
zwingend vorgeschrieben ist
aber ohne zustimmung des
eisenbahnbundesamtes darf man in der
ganzen republik nicht einfach so straßen
auf bahndämme setzen bauplan und
einbau vorgabe beachtung alles und hier
wird einfach die straße auf bahnstrecke
gebaut und wenn jetzt die gelder
zurückgezahlt werden müssen er hat
runter zu leiden
der ganze kreis denn für den bau der
kreisstraße sind 180000 euro
fördermittel vom land geflossen der
freistaat thüringen prüft derzeit ob die
gelder wieder zurückgefordert werden für
den landkreis kann dieses schicke stück
asphalt noch sehr teuer werden